and why schools need to stay closed this
is covid and the classroom we must
apply downward pressure on that upward
curve
by closing the schools
we will take a phased approach in terms
of reopening schools we're going to go
upstairs keeping two metres you'll be
able to see where your table is
i think it would be very unfair for the
students to be marked down on the basis
of what historically has happened
feeling quite happy about coming back to
school although i'm quite stressed
over 85 percent of primary schools will
be opening as
absolutely as expected on the 4th of
january
the government is once again instructing
you to stay at home
primary schools secondary schools and
colleges across
england must move to remote provision
from tomorrow
we will not be able to reopen schools
immediately after half term
we hope to begin opening schools
on monday march the 8th
everybody is just finding this so
difficult and you just feel like you're
failing at everything failing as a
parent
failing as an employee
[Music]
well remote learning and homeschooling
is now something
that many families know all too well
boris johnson has said he hopes it will
be safe to reopen schools in england
from the 8th of march
according to the government's scientific
advisers children are unlikely to get
too ill from coronavirus but they
could be transmitters of the disease and
teachers even more their parents
could be at risk now after nearly a year
of disruption there are increasingly
loud warnings that the impact on mental
health and education could last
for years so lots to discuss
tonight we have a live panel of students
aged between
5 and 17 years old and some parents too
throughout the program they'll be
telling us their stories about remote
learning
and for some of those who are still
going into school
what it's like to be one of the minority
hello to all of you
and welcome and over here we have our
panel of experts clive searle who is a
head teacher
at worthington primary school in sale in
greater manchester
justine greening former education
secretary and founder
of the social mobility pledge and dr
bernanke dubitsker chair of the child
and adolescent faculty at the royal
college of psychiatrists welcome to you
too and we'll certainly be getting
your thoughts in just a moment first
though let's go to maya who is 11 years
old
has just started secondary school and
lives in london uh maya uh second time
you've been off like this certainly
how's it been for you then this time how
are you coping
um i've been finding it quite easy
because
we have a lot of live live lessons
and the teachers are very understanding
of all of us different situations
and they're really kind and everything's
everything's kind of normal but not
normal at the same time
absolutely it's still difficult though
when you can't see your friends even
though you perhaps see them on
on remote learning devices but do you
feel like
you are getting behind and and do you
worry about that
um sort of because i know
me and a lot of my other friends are
staying
till six o'clock still catching up with
work
um but i think our school's very good at
checking that we've done all of our work
we're uploading it and if we haven't
done enough
the teachers will talk to us and they'll
ask us if we're okay
and if we need any extra help well they
sound like they're being very generous
and supportive don't they that's good
maya thank you
in a moment we'll be speaking to lauren
who has two
young boys frank and bill but first
here's a look at their typical day at
home
good job everybody hello i'm lauren
i've been home schooled in frank who
turned four in the summer
he's only started school in reception uh
this september
8 i also have a two-year-old running
around
which makes things challenging at times
it's lunch
time here at home school
the boys are having their sandwiches
feeling quite lucky
actually that i've been furloughed for
my hospitality job
because i don't know when i'd find the
time to work
i think litten often is the key with a
four-year-olds
and so we're gonna put on our weddings
and go for a walk
oh yes the endless meals certainly uh
lauren joins us now on your own uh
because frank and bill
are in bed well done for that it is
seriously hard work isn't it with uh
with young children you have all our
sympathies
are you finding that you're getting
anything done uh with your oldest boy
who's at school
uh yeah we are um because the school
has been so fantastic i was really
anxious
when i heard the schools were closing um
i didn't know what i was going to do
but the school have been so brilliant
we've had online videos
of lessons that's three times a day and
there's resources
we can physically pick up from the
school and so
it's actually not going too bad because
of that help but it's still
very challenging at times yes
challenging is the is the word we hear
often is it not
and what about uh do you have sympathy
for those parents who are not furloughed
who often find they they almost have to
start their working day late at night
and work into the night to catch up
yeah i just don't know how they find the
time really um
my husband worked full-time uh he's
still working from home
i've been furloughed and it's actually
been quite helpful
to have that time because where frank is
only four
he needs me to be with him he's not
independent enough to
log on to lessons and stay sat down you
know he needs that one-on-one help
um so yeah if i was working i just think
i'd be working
so late into the night to get my work
done well lauren will hear more from you
a bit later on for the moment thank you
very much indeed
so have you seen the burden has fallen
on many parents to
homeschool their children some though
are able to use remote learning methods
on video calls like zoom
but the communication does vary hugely
from school to school
and it's fear that some children from
more deprived backgrounds perhaps are
slipping behind
with many families having neither the
kit the electronics
or even the internet connection to make
it all
work well let's bring in one family who
had to build up the basics then before
they started
hajj and india in essex and india let's
go to you first of all i know that
you're
13 just at the age you want to see your
friends
is that the the bit you miss the most
you think about not being in school
yes the social aspect of school
is something i've really been missing um
just hanging out with my friends
facetiming them it's not the same
but also say like physical activities
saying science
stuff like that that we can't do over
zoom is
really i'm really missing it yes i bet
you are and so many children are across
the land aren't they
do you find you can concentrate um
it is very challenging when everybody
seems to migrate to one room
they certainly do in our household do
you find you can get on with the work
and and the question to you too about
do you have fears for the future about
being behind where you should be
um i have been it's very hard to
motivate yourself but i have been
sitting down at my desk and just getting
my work done
if i have to stay later and catch up
with some work i'll do it
um the fear
aspect it is scary because i'm doing my
foundation year of gcses
so it is scary to think
i'm starting my gcses i'm not in school
but hopefully everything will calm down
and we'll be able to go to school soon
and hajj what about you just very
quickly did you have to set yourself up
for all of this remote learning again
yeah well um you know india coming home
we've got the whole family at home now
so everyone's working from home
uh isolating so uh yeah we've had to go
go in and upgrade the broadband and um
you know get new devices and various
other bits and pieces but i must say
it's been you know a tremendous effort
from
india's school and the support we've
received
um with regards to the teachers have
just been absolutely fantastic and and i
think there's
the stories like like likewise across
um the other panelists
whereby the teachers have um gone above
and beyond
so um yeah we're i'm certainly grateful
for the teachers support
because actually being in lockdown with
the kids at home
is an amazing eye opener on how much we
actually do rely on teachers and how
much teachers actually do
well let's see if our head teacher is
smiling shall we heart in india thank
you very much need let's bring in then
uh clive searle head teacher at
worthington primary school in sale you
must be
delighted to hear that but it's families
juggling isn't it
it's schools juggling too you're dealing
with those who are home learning
and you've got kids in as well have you
tried to accommodate more children this
time around
recognizing that it is really beneficial
for them
oh oh certainly and yeah um we've we've
gone from
what an average of about 25 30 children
in the first lockdown
to 180 this time around
so that's a massive change and and
you're right because the juggling of the
the blended learning as we might call it
you know the online offer and the
in-school
offer and the paper at home offer is uh
is tremendously
hard work for every member of staff that
works not just in my school but across
the country
and i i'm delighted and and i would have
been
i would be so proud to be the head
teacher of those young people that have
just spoken there
that they they remain so positive and i
think that that is such a huge key to
this
and as a school leader i i say to to
to every member of staff that's working
right throughout the country throughout
this
this pandemic every school member of
staff
protect yourselves keep strong and know
that you're doing
an absolutely brilliant job and every
good school in the country
is doing just that right now it's very
very difficult you
absolutely spot on but but people are
working
flat out all the time and
and certainly for my staff i could not
be happier or more proud of them
well you're speaking up for for
everybody there aren't you clive cell or
mr searle i should probably call you
uh let's bring in then uh another child
shall we who has just moved up also to
secondary school
saliq aged 11 so in year seven
and i know saliq that it is really
tricky going to a new school
harder still to make friends in the age
of covid where playgrounds are all
separated and everything aren't they
now you're stuck at home do you feel
that it's been quite hard
sally can you hear us lovely
um it's a can
yes can you hear him i was just saying
it i find it
hugo um
yeah it's been quite tricky for me
because
um i've got a little sister who
sometimes distracts me during online
lessons
and there's also and the wi-fi goes out
and things like that
so and um i get distracted
quite a lot so yeah it is quite hard for
me
well i bet it is salic thank you very
much indeed it's a big delay this is the
world of homeschooling i guess isn't it
as well
um let's bring in former education
secretary now
founder of the social mobility pledge
justine greening
um everyone's having different
experiences aren't they justine
children have different needs also at
different ages and on top of that
the fear that the most deprived are
simply the most disadvantaged through
this experience
that's right and i mean first of all a
massive thank you to all of the
work by teachers like clive and around
the country it's been incredible what
they've done and as he said now having
to not only teach
at school but also manage teaching
remotely as well
and we should say a big thank you to
them and also parents like hard you are
no doubt exhausted at having to home
school but doing their best and
and people like lauren but we need to
recognize that
children will have had very different
experiences through this
what has now been nearly a year of
disruption of education so
coming out of that what we need is to
make sure we give schools
the support they need to do catch up
properly so
in no way should we shortchange that we
need to make sure they have absolutely
the resources they need to help their
children catch up where that's necessary
and i think longer term we need to
recognize that
if this is a government that wants to do
leveling up then we need
a framework for that some leveling up
goals but education is
absolutely going to be at the heart of
that and i think what no one wants
is for this generation of amazing young
people
to pay the longer term price for having
been part of this covered pandemic
i think the final thing perhaps to say
is that
there's been a lot of lost learning and
teachers have done their level best to
minimize that
but there's also the fact that children
have been out of school
missing their friends you know there are
mental health challenges that they face
as a result and we need to not forget
all of that um as we look ahead to the
kind of support that young people and
children will need
to help them get beyond the damage that
this pandemic has brought
well i mean definitely some good
messages and the prime minister
definitely talking about the money for
catch-up learning yesterday
justine greening thank you very much
indeed well let's bring in then one mom
who certainly has her hands full
sadief najmi mum of six hats off to you
uh and you're joined by some of your
children who we've got who've we got
here then
we've got samaya safiya hawa and
do you have to be really well organized
i have to ask you that
extremely extremely well organized yet
definitely any secrets for people
because they'll be dying to know how you
how you manage
you know every day we take each day as
it comes we have to take
each day as it comes we don't look too
far into the future
just we wake up every morning and think
right today we're gonna get through
this and then we wait until the next day
and do the same thing again
well if i can grab a word with a couple
of your girls how are let's talk to you
first of all
are there any good bits about being at
home
what do you like about being at home
she was probably she's probably happier
at school where she can see everybody at
school
absolutely well let's ask your older
sister then samaya you're 12
aren't you uh what do you most miss
about school then
what do you miss about um i'm not i miss
seeing my friends and i miss um doing
like
actual lessons because we have to do
them live now
so yeah and uh ikra here
you're five aren't you i'm guessing that
you're in reception
do you miss your teacher
yes you do what's mommy is mommy as good
as your teacher
how's mommy
mommy doesn't have as much patience
honestly
we know that don't we thank you very
much to all of you the nigerian family
there with the
six children at home well there we go
more of your thoughts from our panel in
a moment first though to another home
video you might recognize
this one eleven-year-old braden is a
presenter on sky's fyi the news program
for young people
braden like many others is forced to do
his school work from home and he's been
documenting
his day for this program
now we're just gonna kind of show you me
and kiera what a day in her life is like
in lockdown with us for me my morning's
not that bad
i've got my teammate toast uh bagel in
fact
and i've got german and then english so
that's my morning
okay we're watching all morning like um
i've got maths spanish and spellings but
the thing that i'm most looking forward
to is my zoom
where i can see my friends and my
teachers good morning
now we're out in the garden getting our
steps up come on
so it's the end of the day just finished
my last lesson and i just finished a
call with my friends
it's obviously not like being at school
but we're still getting on with it and
to be fair i've not had a bad day
oh good for him brayden and kyra there
thanks to them but of course schools are
not
closed children of parents who are key
workers are still
able to go to school along with children
who are considered
vulnerable well let's bring in faith
oliver then and faith
that you are 17 currently in year 12
you're still going into school does it
feel a strange experience for you in
these
somewhat empty classrooms
well we're not actually in the
classrooms which i know is a similar
experience for most people that are
still in school
we do virtual learning but in school so
i sit in the pastoral office and do
online lessons
with about 10 to 20 kids in
wow so that's so you're not even going
into the classrooms then
and do you get any interaction with
other children or are you are you quite
separated off from people
we're socially distanced from people
we're allowed to speak to them but it's
wearing your masks getting tested
making sure everyone's safe and it's
your age range isn't it that have really
found this hard it's a time where you'd
be going out on your own
you'd be going to parties you'd be you'd
be meeting all sorts of new people
have you have you found it tough and and
if so what's been the the toughest bit
i think for a lot of young people the
impacts of not being able to go out and
see people face to face contact so many
people people's a big thing
the impacts of having to keep up with so
much schoolwork
when you're at home when people have
such difficult home circumstances that
aren't always picked up by schools
i know a lot of young people actually
that don't have access to the internet
my colleagues have had to give out 700
laptops that they've had to pay for out
of their own money because the
government hasn't supported them
and 60 of the students at my school are
in poverty
so they're really really struggling with
online resources to the point where
college are having to send them
notebooks
so they can write down what they're
doing and
i feel like the biggest difficulty for
most young people is the fact that
actually we are not getting any clarity
off the government
we have no clue what is actually going
on with our exams we don't know when
we're going back we don't know about uni
applications
so the support that we're getting off
teachers is excellent
but the information being related to us
by government is
shocking faith we wish you the very best
of luck obviously
and uh you know there's a lot of concern
about your age range and everybody
trying to
get some normality as we as we head
forward but best of luck thank you very
much indeed
well let's bring in another family now
also benefiting from schools being open
a family who did homeschool first time
around
with twins who both have adhd both
in year five at primary school found it
tough the first time
found that progress was really difficult
for those children at home
as i have to say many of us did so let's
bring in dad mark alongside his twins
elena
and reuben who are nine reuben let's go
to you first of all
um is this better than the first
lockdown are you glad you're going into
school
um yeah because i'm playing with friends
i learned something new
every day whenever i get stuck on
something it's happening always helps me
i love going to school oh that's good
and what about you
and i think i might be pronouncing your
name properly is it elena
yeah oh there we go right and so what
about for you then you're going to
school is it quite a relief do you think
that your parents
dad next to you doesn't have to teach
you anymore
and yeah because i get to see my friends
and the teachers
oh dear what subjects have you been
doing this week then
um math english
science and history
very good that's why i'm amazed you can
remember i can't remember what i did
yesterday
and uh mark the twins are both home for
the first lockdown
i know you struggle to make progress
does it make such a difference going for
them going into school right now
it's absolutely huge and it's
i think having children with special
educational needs as well as so trying
to home school
it just became apparent really within
the first few weeks of that process that
despite all our best efforts it just
really wasn't going to plan
and as parents we just felt that we
weren't
we just weren't able to provide them
with the right sort of
educational support and support that
they need and
um around that time um we spoke to the
school
and we explained the situation and
then between ourselves we just came to
sort of you know strong conclusion that
for reuben elena and you know for their
development they are better off in the
school setting
and have to say straight away it were
fantastic and
they had their routine and structure
back straight away they were able to
sort of um
you know be with their friends and over
that particular
some of their their greats or their
learning um
remained you know from our point of view
an excellent level so
the teachers for school the same pieces
were absolutely amazing
and it really was a saving grace for us
as a family
and i do have to say that you know my
instinct tells me that
um you know each one of us has a long um
different situations resorts to manage
really and
it just you know it became clear to us
that that was the best you know
situation for our children uh mark just
very briefly i know you've got a
question for the panel as well
go for it yeah certainly um
all it is if we're entering into more
potential lockdowns
over the next few months does the panel
feel that it may be
a good option to develop a national
strategy
specific for vulnerable and send young
people
okay let's let's put that to justine if
you don't mind answering it very briefly
because we want lots more to pack in
yes absolutely i think parents of
special needs children need to have the
reassurance
that if this happens again there will be
better provision in the future
justine greenlee thank you very much
indeed good
well the issue obviously of mental
health is one of the key concerns isn't
it that anxiety the stress the downright
loneliness for some children has been a
key concern
and today came the suggestion that the
mental health impact of the pandemic
could last for years to come without a
large-scale
increase in support for young people
that according to a new report from the
children's commissioner ann longfield
well the report estimates that one in
six children
aged between five and 19 had a mental
health disorder
last year that is up from one in nine
children
three years ago referrals to children's
mental health services
are also up by more than a third
well before we speak to dr bernard
dubitsker
chair of the royal college of
psychiatrists uh let's bring in
esther uh you are 15 years old esther in
year 11
and you saw support didn't you after the
stress of your mock exams tell us how
you were feeling and
and what you did okay so
i was really lucky to have help and
support from action for children who
gave me coping mechanisms and strategies
in order to
feel less stressed and get on with my
day better
they came into my school for six weeks i
was in their program
and they just put us in small groups so
we didn't feel as intimidated
and help me realize that i'm not the
only one who's struggling and
helped me feel more secure within myself
esther thank you very much indeed much
appreciated for that
uh well let's have uh well it is tough
no doubt
let's uh let's bring in now our doctor
dr dubiska
you've heard some of the children there
i mean many of them are coping really
really well aren't they
um but there are concerns about being
behind the pressure on school
exams may have gone but you're still
worried about every piece of homework
you hand in
what do you think the main problems are
and how they should be tackled
yes thank you for having me it was great
to hear from all these children young
people there's a huge variety of
experience as you've heard
but i really want to highlight the
plight of the most vulnerable children
young people
so firstly most children people will be
okay they will get through this and
we've heard
some of the resilient children this
evening but there are an awful lot of
children young people that's highlighted
by long and long field who are really
really struggling
so even before the pandemic we know that
we weren't treating
75 percent of children young people with
mental health disorders
and we've seen that demand has just
escalated
referrals are coming into camps as never
before they're at the highest peak ever
and it's absolutely urgent as justine
has just said we really do need an
urgent particles
about how we're going to address this
issue right here and now
but also looking into the future because
the sooner we we can intervene and help
these vulnerable children young people
the quicker they can get better and the
quicker they can have their life chances
brought back for them
dr davitska thank you very much indeed
well from all of us here we wish you the
very best of luck obviously a big thank
you then to all the students and parents
tonight thank you to you
thank you too to our panel of experts
much appreciated
and if you enjoyed today's program there
are more discussions like this on fyi
the week